welcome to this video playing as master
gal poon from Russia it's a Russian for
like at least a gallon let's see this
looks like an old Indian nope
transposing to a king's onion yeah
fairly close Kings Indian position
Nigerian 92 unpunished this is a really
nice Kings Indian like wait wait wait
wait even H force is a move here on I or
simply 9292 f5f three bishop age six
could be 11 idea that is trying to go
for I can also go G for witches which is
not bad now let's let's do g4 it's both
good really h 4g 492 or both is wrong i
think they're all interesting
g4 of course play to make f5 more
difficult to play even group g1 as a
possible follow up to make sure that f5
is really not coming ok where do I put
my pieces h4 is not a good idea maybe
this one it's usually good on on the G
file to to meet this this f 5m if I go H
for now as this is this possible or an
idea yeah well f5 maybe gains a little
bit in strength hey we just go back not
sure about rook g1 the more that I think
of it as usual those kind of super
committal moves are played instantly
actually believe that this cannot be
good for black but ok let's see how to
do it um let's grab here first and then
the Bishop to g4 I am trading of light
squared Bishop should be nice and if he
goes to d3 I have this have it always
check in nightly fire as well now maybe
he still should play Bishop d3 to have
some sort of murkiness in the position
murkiness is a word I will tend to keep
it keep it and keep it complicated
that's what I'm what I'm trying to say
ok so just clean g4 I Alice's fitting
into the position rook f-4s maybe a move
I look at for is a move
not sure how dangerous it is but it is a
move now the dark squares are not that
great yeah definitely not okay group g6
now a threat okay I can take now they're
on g6 and not sure if it is any good
then nighty for stuff like that yeah
okay I really cannot allow him to come
to a 4 with the night that that really
is something that I should do ah no yes
that move are we were no ah yes you
hated to lose against this opening when
when they especially when they play such
a bad line as 97 and stuff like that but
yeah it is still tricky and i miss
plated yeah i really miss played it from
a technical point of view and even
before that now ah what the vet gave now
maybe i should really not go with g4
stuff it's so it is often good but it is
so complicated that they get this this
kind of wacky counter play all the time
yeah 95 would be nice I can actually do
that maybe I shoot them rook takes a 97
a night f7 is actually quite nice hmm
maybe that is not that bad it is tricky
for both sides now all affair hmm i go
to age 5 he is doing what hook edge form
so I cannot do that this one yeah I
don't I don't see any other Wow maybe d6
as a move d 6 d 6 and 95 or stuff like
that let's let's get get get the King
out of it I'm sure page six you can play
yeah I see the moves right after I play
them but I mean why why am I not
thinking for just one moment to see all
those contracts is frustrating early to
overlook all this stuff damn that's just
lost that's just plain lost
is that any way to swindle hear
something you can just take it with the
pawn I mean you can just take it with
the pawn and I have no point whatsoever
95 Queen takes g5 and I just give up
there is no no point whatsoever yeah
exactly this is the problem
time morning yeah that's it three no
matter he can just take g5 this guy
irritates me to no end yeah for a
difficult move see he spends no time and
for just taking away stuff he spends
ages yeah I can resign him this is why
resigns yeah let's let's seven look at
this the thing is that this is really
really just bad for black it's just like
that bad but I'm not punishing it this
makes me always angry a vehicles they
get away with stuff that they shouldn't
get away with how to play that you
simply cannot play a five when I play G
for Andrew bg1 now this is just a
playing totally into white set up the
thing is that i'm playing badly
afterwards how do i do that so Bishop
Bishop c5 sometimes this is an idea in
those positions maybe not when the night
is only eight it gives up dark square
control for light square control the
problem is that may be in this concrete
position it does not does not help the
computer wants to go Quincy to and gives
fighter pretty clear edge but Quincy to
looks yeah it's nothing that i would
consider I it's not a bad move and it
controlled Z form and maybe this was
really really bad Jack you have the main
problem is that here I mean what am I
playing next this is such a huge problem
the rook to F for now this is this is
overruling everything else yeah control
of before or whatnot look at four is the
problem
and maybe I really shouldn't play stuff
with chief wire I mean this is also just
good for white with totally normal moves
castles 92 whatever and i really don't i
don't don't play those kind of super
complicated positions too well and I
mean stuff like 97 and 98 SS really
should be punished and I'm really I'm
really wondering and maybe 92 it's not
right that's possible that it is better
to to keep the night on your three for
the moment so that after f5 take stakes
and I g5 is coming looking to to go to
e6 now maybe Mary this this opening is
very complicated this is also the reason
why black players keep playing that
stuff even if it is bad it's very hard
to refute especially in those those
slower those quick turn control games
and I personally would would render the
stuff here for black s almost unplayable
in tournament chess very very difficult
people might disagree there will be
people who live love the Kings in you
think this is great but it is really not
but it is difficult to play maybe I
already should do H foyer and keep the
night there which means that move like
this it always has not there it always
has this additional idea the night is
just near near the king in that tech and
here i also have h5 this is very hard to
believe that black can run right into
this attack maybe maybe this year
computer wants to play this funny move
which is really set going back to f6 and
then wants to go here i am now that
that's really really cute yeah
something like that is of course
overwhelming and white has such a huge
space advantage okay next time next time
I need to play a little bit more solid
against this this this kind of setup
thanks for watching